i'm curious what uh with the show
what was your guys's like favorite part
like funniest moments
like that well first of all coming from
the english love island and that first
season of the american love island was
dudu yeah and i have to bring this up a
little bit
the dude is one of the dudes at cbs who
was a part of the buying process to
license out
love island to uh cbs
he caught cody and i getting breakfast
one day
and we we played the love island game on
youtube for a little while
and he goes man i think you guys
helped get people to understand what
love island is you know
i i'm certain of it i think it's because
of you guys we were able to bring love
island over to the states
and we were like cool involve us and
they just never did
which was which was whack no we were
going to fly out
did marty gonna die in the game
yeah so that was one thing they wanted
to do they actually for
the english like half season when they
shot it in south africa they were going
to have us go there
and film there but because of kovid they
said nah or no
maybe we were touring it it might have
been both either way
so we're never really able to make
anything happen
so i think at least for me personally i
became jaded with the show because i'm
like man we
putting all this love and you guys dick
us around [ __ ] you guys
yeah so so when this season came out
you know because of covet i'm like i
guess we'll watch it and for
for me i was blown away by how good it
was
and i think they painted you in such a
way
i think they made people hate you at the
front
but they knew they were like oh this guy
we're gonna take him to the end
and he's gonna [ __ ] so you know
candidly i think you were one of the
best characters on the show there was i
saw a meme that was like
i was on the love island reddit
i just i just found out what it was
and i went on it and there was a meme
that said the villain and it was a
picture of you and then it was like the
real villain and it was a picture of
johnny
or it was like the tv villain it was
like a tv villain it was you
or then it was like the real villain and
it was johnny yeah funny
no that's that's [ __ ] yeah when i was
in there
so when new people come in they uh they
kind of get a glimpse of what's going on
at first to give them like a head start
you know what i mean
yeah um and i talked to i got along with
pretty much [ __ ] everybody i'd say
the one person i
didn't really was just caitlyn and
that's just because
she was there for like two days you know
i mean so yeah they would come in
and they would all kind of like at first
just be a little weird towards me i'm
like
where's this resentment coming from but
it's because they saw should i have it
you know i mean so they probably think
i'm a scumbag
and then we just all became way good
friends so when they all left
the show they'd go on podcasts and like
the after the island youtube thing or
whatever and uh
they all just say good things so i think
that all saved my ass
because if they learn and people would
just be like all i see is this yeah this
guy [ __ ] sucks so
yeah so you do think they cut you like a
little bit
bad yeah i've never been one to say it
like everyone else has said it for me
because i'm not trying to be a [ __ ]
about it but at the end of the day
because you you've never been on tv
before this right no that's my first
time yeah
have you ever done anything like really
on camera before no
no i mean that's 100 it you've never
done it so you're just you're just
being genuine like they ask you a
question you're just shooting answers
and then
you're right producers they're like
they're like who do you like the least
here and you're like oh
cool i'll answer that yeah perfect
straight up no i i was way honest just
because like there was times i talked
around the point but
i did not want to get caught lying on tv
i was like that's like a
scumbag move so i was just pretty honest
about [ __ ]
i just tried not to be in a situation
where i had to be honest about like
a certain person or just do that you
know i mean bro i think that highlights
a weird thing about americans where
i feel in america we put so much
emphasis on
uh other people's feelings like you
should have sensitivity towards other
people's feelings
yeah we're talking some english people
and they're saying they hated
working with americans because they
could go in i think i was actually
talking one of elena's cousins
he said he hates dealing with americans
because he'll pitch something or he'll
have a meeting
and they're all smiles but he knows as
soon as the door closes
americans are like we're not [ __ ]
working with that guy that guy was a
[ __ ] and so i feel there was this
expectation on you i mean i was guilty
of it of being like oh
carrington shouldn't be that blunt with
people and he should be more sensitive
to how
but in the end you you you were right
like you had to be that way
but although yeah and here's here's
another thing is that
that's kind of what love island was
about from the get-go at least
on the british version yeah about like
backstabbing and hooking up with people
and
that was kind of the fun of the show in
the beginning right it wasn't really
about like the long-term relationships
that blossom
am i am i wrong i think that's right no
it was more about like just
people like having fun like it was more
kind of like the real world i guess
or something like that have you ever
where it wasn't actually about finding
love but now the american version like i
feel like america's so like just
bachelor in bachelorette and that's all
we've known
for so long that people crave like the
oh they want like the
you know like the like the marriage that
comes out of this i want like yeah
and so like you said it's like it's
supposed to be a dating show but then
all of a sudden like you date a couple
of people and people were like [ __ ] you
this guy's a scum yeah
no and straight up so when i was going
on
everyone always like nobody wants to be
and i wouldn't even say i was in a
negative way i really wouldn't like yeah
i talked around but at the end of it i
think i came out i was happy with how i
was shown
um but when i was going in of course in
my mind it's like all right like
you know being the sweetheart guy blah
blah everyone thinks that
and then you get in there and [ __ ] just
changes and you're kind of like do i
wanna
fake things for the money or do i wanna
actually get to know this girl
say this girl's like up my alley or
she's not i'm still gonna talk to her
and get to know her
just because who knows if we do like
each other and if not i'll move on but
yeah i went in there and very fast i was
like i can't fake this just for the
money like
i'm just gonna be real and i feel like
it's been a while since
and maybe i'm wrong on a show like this
where people haven't
necessarily just played the game to get
to the finals like i put myself in the
position to go home
many times from just being honest and
that's what i think saved me so
yep yep yep no i i
think uh not 100 i think you played it
in a lot of ways that most people would
not
have the comfort of doing i think most
people would default to
you know that's why what's her name
what was she english or she was english
oh lauren
lauren yeah i think yeah i think
whatever i mean i understood why she got
annoyed when she left because
she's kind of saying what you're saying
she's out [ __ ] like
none of you guys even tried you know
like all of you want to be cold
oh damn i forgot about her yeah she got
so pissed
that was uh she was that was so
unexpected and
when i watched the back i knew i didn't
even know she did the same thing in the
girls room they're like helping her back
her back she's like
it's like so [ __ ] fake yeah you're
all you're all so [ __ ] fake
and i was like what i was like she said
that to your faces
[Laughter]
yeah so um so
you you think you're gonna make the move
out here or are you just gonna post in
salt lake until
can you guys hear that i'm sorry is that
it no no i can barely hear it
all right you guys hear me with these
yeah i don't have like i don't got like
the big nice
dildos [ __ ] mics i got these little
[ __ ] out whoa so
shots fired i just kidding no there's
that thing to suck on over there like
nerds like you [ __ ] reddit
over there with their [ __ ] over there
dude i [ __ ] i love that we're talking
i've watched you guys for so [ __ ]
long that when i clicked the video and
saw my face i was like goddamn
what did you think when noel said you
were a fish with teeth
bro when i saw that
i was just like okay we'll see where it
goes and it kind of ended and i was like
because some people get like 15 minute
videos about them you know i mean like
the doughboy
whatever yeah i was just thinking [ __ ]
if this is 15 minutes of me
i might have to unsubscribe
i know it was cool the next couple epis
the next like two you did it was just
kind of like
bringing up some funny [ __ ] i did and uh
you know i thought it was funny
in the end i mean i'm pretty sure you
can watch like the progression by the
end of it i said you know i sit on
carrington but i like that guy
i walked it back i did i walked it back
what did we not like
do you remember i didn't like um uh
what's up with mckenzie what's her face
a mackenzie but like yeah i mean i the
fact that they're still together
mackenzie and what's his face connor
yeah connor dude what do you think of
that
was it really as toxic as it looked
like i tried to i tried to have them not
talk for a sec you know what i mean so
that was my favorite moments of the show
is when you came over
and tried to save that like conversation
from happening what did you say you were
like
i said hey can i borrow him
i have to tell him something important
something ridiculous because i didn't
know what to say like what
what am i going to be where are we going
like out across the street to caesar's
like
we're not going anywhere like i got
nothing to [ __ ] tell him so
i did that it didn't work so i went back
dude that that gave me a specific memory
one time of me being high as
god and uh walking up to some dudes that
were like
parked by my like my homie's car and i
was just high as [ __ ] and i was like and
my my boy got to move his car and
they're like the
[ __ ] who are you they wanted to fight me
it was just weird like what the [ __ ] am
i doing here not even the same thing
but it was the look that she gave the
look that she gave you after you said
that and you were like
or we could just do it later yeah yeah
i'm actually
it's funny so mckenzie's kind of on a
similar page to me with kind of how
she's
seen i feel like but uh sure he's
actually a pretty cool
like pretty cool girl man and the only
thing i feel like that that really made
her look that way was the relationship
with connor and
i didn't see like i wasn't there with
them dating throughout the whole [ __ ]
time like i'm doing my own thing
yeah i just saw bits and pieces yeah
towards the end i just kind of figured
like
they probably shouldn't talk especially
after all the cost of more [ __ ]
so um but they're working out now it's i
think it just goes to show like dating
and meeting for the first time dating
ass backwards living with someone
than having to be loyal three days in
but also having to like do your own
thing and talk to other people
all that combined stress probably just
doesn't make anything work inside of the
you know
yeah no that's that's such a fair way to
put it you know yeah
um i definitely think
she's a different kind of person than
than me but
uh i think they're perfect for each
other i think they're gonna i think
they're gonna go the distance honestly
clearly who else would they get married
to you know what i'm saying they're
perfect
yeah yeah yeah yeah i did clown connor
for having a like a
like a it's a weird it's a weird roast
but he had a tiny ass tongue
it was a disproportionate tongue to his
face oh my god
he's got a pretty he's got a pretty
small head too yeah it's just like he
got like a little shih tzu face like you
know
he'll see this and then be like why does
he talk like this he's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
he's not even
to see that he's he's a nice guy though
he's nice yeah i'm gonna leave him alone
i'm leaving him yeah
he means one yeah yeah he is honestly
like yeah he's
i mean because for a second he got you
know and he he knows it too like for a
second
he got walked on he realized it and so
he kind of backed off from
mckenzie but yeah he's honestly one of
the i've never met someone so nice i was
like damn bro like how are you this nice
all the time yeah
yeah you know that that was one thing
that
blew my [ __ ] mind about him is i'm
like this will
it's like he's just lived in some weird
bubble where
he's not interacting with the real world
and he just has this genuine sort of he
doesn't think anyone has ulterior motive
he takes everyone he's like a puppy
almost yeah
but i don't i hesitate to say that
because i'm not trying to call him an
idiot you know what i mean i just feel
they're smart puppies they're not
associating puppies with
pissing and [ __ ] themselves so oh
yeah but they love
unconditionally true i agree with you on
that though i think he's never
i don't think anything bad has ever
happened i'm like good for him because
he's always just been
if he stays as genuine his whole life
and nice like [ __ ] that's a good guy
if there's a heaven he's going to it you
know what i mean yeah
but not you you're going straight to it
now i'm joking yes yes
or worse yeah
you